boycott Burger King they hate free
speech and due process and their food is
poison anyway stop eating it I just want
to pause and say if you've been eating
Burger King for any reason
please don't I think Burger King is just
awful but that's just my opinion I mean
I'm not gonna be smirched the good name
of Burger King I guess is this Charlie
Kirk saying it's poison I wonder what
the the the legalities on that calling
it poison I think that's like I don't
know if you can say that but I guess
it's an opinion statement I think Burger
King is unhealthy and I'd be I think
it's very would be very funny if Burger
King started suing people for claiming
their food is bad for you because it is
bad for you you know they're onion rings
I don't even know what their onion rings
are I got the best I think they're onion
rings are potatoes no for real have you
ever had Burger King onion rings like
years ago I'm pretty sure it's I well in
my opinion it does not it's not an onion
like it's it's some kind of mashed
something or other they cut into a ring
yeah just not good